>> From the Library of
congress in Washington, DC.
>> Colleen Shogan: I think
we're all looking forward
to this superstar roundtable
on congressional reform.
There's two suppositions that are
commonly discussed whether you watch
television talk shows or
read popularly about congress
and those are that congress
is dysfunctional and that
that dysfunction can be solved or
remedied by congressional reform.
And I think we're going to talk
about both of those suppositions
in this roundtable and
possibly challenge both of them.
This panel is being
chaired by Matt Glassman
of the congressional
Research Service
and I'm going to turn
it over to him.
>> Matt Glassman: Thanks Colleen.
I am Matt Glassman from the
congressional Research Service here
at the Library of congress
and I'm thrilled
to be moderating this panel.
I am going to say a few words
to frame the discussion,
but first I want to introduce
each of our panelists,
even though I think for most of us
they don't need any introductions.
Sitting to my direct left here
is congressman Mickey Edwards
who served Oklahoma's fifth district
for 16 years, a former member
of appropriations committee
and budget committee and also
in the leadership as chairman of the
house republican policy committee.
congressman Edwards is a founding
trustee of the Heritage Foundation
and a prolific writer and
commentator on all things congress.
Next to Congressman Edwards is David
Mayhew, Sterling Professor Emeritus
of political science
at Yale University.
Professor Mayhew has written on
congress both in scholarly outlets
and popular press for over 50 years.
Most of us are familiar
with his second book,
Congress the Electoral
Connection published in 1974,
perhaps the foundational political
science work on how to think
about congressional action.
By my account in this room there
are at least four dissertations
that were supervised by
Professor Mayhew, including mine
and that may be a lowball
count there.
Next, we have Congressman David Obey
who represented the seventh district
of Wisconsin for 42 years, one
of the longest-serving members
of the house of representatives
from 1969 to 2011.
Congressman Obey was chair of
the appropriations committee both
in 1994 and again,
from 2007 until 2011.
Congressman Obey has
been a participant
on numerous reorganization
efforts in congress,
most notably the 94th congress
on the Obey commission.
Next is Eric Schickler,
professor of political science
at the University of Berkeley.
Eric's the author of Disjointed
Pluralism, Institutional Innovation
and the Development
of the US Congress,
which won the [inaudible] award
and also had a huge influence on me
and certainly an entire generation
of scholars in how to think
about congressional change.
And finally, we have Sarah Binder,
senior fellow at the Brookings
Institute and professor
of political science at the
George Washington University.
Sarah's written numerous
books on American politics,
including Stalemate Causes and
Consequences of Legislative Gridlock
and Minority Rights and
Majority Rule, Partisanship
and the Development of Congress.
Sarah's also an associate editor
at the popular Money Cage blog here
in DC and she also provides
a lightning fast analysis
of all things trending
in the senate,
even stuff that just happened
this week so we look forward
to hearing from her about that.
We have about 75 minutes
for the panel.
I've been told to reserve the second
half of the time for questions
from the audience, we may
spend even more there,
I'm sure everyone has
questions for our panel.
In lieu of any sort
of opening statements
from the panelists I'm going
to say a few brief words to try
and frame the debate and then I'm
going to pose a few questions I have
to the panel, but hopefully they
will just be sort of general nature
to get them talking and then we
can get the questions you may have
as well.
So, it's become customary I would
say in the last hundred years
to introduce any discussion
of congressional reform
with reference to two signposts.
First, the dismal approval
ratings of congress and second,
the wisdom of Woodrow Wilson and
I am I'm going to disappoint you
on either of those counts.
Congress has rarely been popular
in public opinion approval polls,
but the contemporary
dissatisfaction appears
to be even greater than normal.
The most recent handful
of Gallup polls finds
about 20% approval
rating for congress,
which is actually considerably up
from their 2015 single digit lows
that you might be familiar with.
But this is all still
solidly below their average
in the last 50 years,
considerably lower.
Wilson's scathing critiques of
congress in the late 19th century
and early 20th century of
course, weren't the first
to lament the inefficiencies
of the legislature
or declare the separation
of the power system
outmoded in the modern world.
But they were however
among the first
to systematically diagnose
the problem as one
that could perhaps be overcome
or at least improved upon
through purposeful
institutional change
and he certainly was not
the last to claim this.
This celebrated tradition
carries on to today,
in fact you don't even need to
specify what branch you're talking
about when you write a book
called the broken branch,
no one thinks you mean
the court system.
But at the same time,
no one writes a book
with that title unless they believe
that what's broken can be fixed
and unless they think that
what's broken is fundamental
if not primary to the system.
Of course, a key challenge of
diagnosing and reforming congress is
that no one really agrees on what
a functioning congress looks like.
For some like Wilson had
a responsible party flavor
in which a majority party can easily
enact its national program upon the
greased skids of strong leadership,
majoritarian rules and parliamentary
like discipline among
the rank-and-file.
For others it's largely
the opposite,
a decentralized legislature
with strong committees
bolting a policy expertise
that can thoughtfully craft
durable and successful policy
and multiple [inaudible] points that
require the meaningful participation
and deliberation of all
members, including the minority.
Still others don't even think
about it in this dimension
and when they think about
congressional form they're looking
to seek or increase the relative
power of congress outside
of the legislative arena and the
entire constitutional structure
by finding ways to augment
the political capacity,
power and prestige
of the institution
against the executive branch.
And of course, all this is
complicated by the ever-present fact
that congressional reform is a
process of collective action.
And so, layered on top of any vision
of a more functional congress are
all the short-term incentives both
members and citizens have, policy
incentives, partisan incentives,
and powerbase incentives
that may choose
to sacrifice long-term broad
institutional objectives
for short-term narrow
benefits or vice versa.
And so, we find ourselves at the
opening of the 150th congress
with a conventional wisdom certainly
around town in DC and I think wider
around the country that we have
an unpopular institution mired
in gridlock despite the promise of
unified control of the governments.
And a perception that it's
ever weakening in the face
of internal stalemate and external
power zapping from the executive.
And as this is a congress in history
roundtable I want to make sure
that we pay particular attention
to how the current
situation fits into the past.
Is this a uniquely
problematic time for congress
or can we find similar situations
in the past to guide our thinking
about the prospects
and possibilities of
congressional reform?
Likewise, what can we learn
from history by the value
of specific reforms or about the
political conditions that produce
and don't produce reform.
There's probably something of
a Tolstoy problem at work here
that every dysfunctional congress
is dysfunctional in its own way.
But I'd like to think we have the
scholarly experience on this panel,
as well as the membership and
legislator experience to try
and leverage what we do know
about the past to the degree
that it can affect
the current congress.
And so, I want to start with kind of
the broadest question I can think of
and that is also in the place
where everyone is starting
in Washington these days and that's
with party polarization okay.
There's a perception that the
increasing polarization is the root
cause of all of the
dysfunction in congress.
And broadly speaking, this is
divided reformers into two camps.
First, the ones who want to
accept party polarization okay
as just our new reality and
transform the institutions
to better match that okay, I'm
thinking here again Woodrow Wilson
or the APSA committee in the 50's
or Tom Mann and Norm Orenstein okay.
Democratize the institution,
strengthen the leadership
and make it possible for
the parties as strong
as they are to take command.
But there's an opposing force
that says no, reformers should try
and constrain and channel
the party polarization
and find ways to mitigate it.
Seek reforms that encourage
deliberation, negotiation
and compromise and increase
the capacity of congress okay,
return to an older expertise based
legislative institution that's not
just an arena for party battles,
but is actually a transformative
institution and a primary feature
of the system as a whole.
So that's the first question
I want to take to the panel
and I will take anyone who would
like to jump in and participate.
In the age of party polarization,
what does a functional
congress look like?
What would you like to see congress
behaving like now and should we try
to mitigate the party problem
or should we accept it and try
and shape the institutions
to take advantage of it?
>> Mickey Edwards: Well,
I'll say something to start
because the first thing I wanted to
say was, you know, how pleased I am
to be here with my good
friend, David Obey.
And there was a time when we worked
together republican and democrat,
liberal or conservative and we
worked together because we believed
in the institution and I
didn't ever know anybody
who was more an institutionalist,
more a representative
of what congress was supposed
to be than David Obey.
And I'm just, you know, excited
to be with you again Dave so.
>> David Obey: Thank you.
>> Mickey Edwards: I would just
make a couple of observations.
I don't really see the problem
as polarization I see it
as partisanship and
they're different
because they're two
different things.
And I also think that when
you have serious problems
in any entity it's usually either
because you have the wrong people
so you have members of congress
who are stupid, don't know anything
about or -- and I don't think
that's the case or its systemic,
there's something wrong
with the system
that is producing the
results that we have.
So, Wilson and is not the only one
who thought that the separation
of parties system was outmoded,
I think that the our current
domination, the system of domination
of our parties, of our
politics, our elections
and our internal governance of
congress is outmoded, it's outdated,
it's a relic of the past.
We don't do anything in our lives,
we don't run anything in our lives
by dividing into two
rival clubs to fight it
out as though they were
rival football teams except
for the way we run the congress
and that's what we reward.
We have a party primary system
that rewards intransigence,
we have the sore loser laws that
allow party ideologues to determine
who can be on the ballot in November
that we're paying for that price.
And I think 20 years from now
over 50% of Americans are going
to be registered as independents and
they're going to look back and say,
oh there was a time when people
thought everything should be a fight
between party A and
party B and they're going
to wonder what were we
thinking when we tried
to govern our country that way.
So that's one of the
problems that I see.
And I think the second problem,
the other one I'll mention,
is that among the members
of congress
that I observe today are too many
who don't understand what the role
of congress is, they don't
understand article one,
they don't know what their
powers and responsibilities are.
Too many refer to the
executive as the boss or act
as though the president is the boss
and it's their job to
carry out his agenda.
The news media reports all the
time about whether or not the party
in control is going to be able to
carry out the president's agenda.
So, unless -- given the current
system unless we are able
to get a congress that not only
has the capacity to do the job
that it was elected to do, but
understands where its powers are,
whether it's domestic
policy or foreign policy
which the courts have repeatedly
held was a congressional authority
not a legislative, not a
presidential authority.
Unless we get to where
congress understands its duty
and does its duty we're going to be
here 20 years from now and talking
about the exact same things and
asking why is it dysfunctional.
And so, I'm wanting some really
fundamental, basic changes.
>> David Mayhew: I'm not
dysfunctionalist, there are a lot
of problems out there, most of
them don't reside in congress
or are not generated by congress
they're problems with the parties,
with the society itself, with
the elections, with the media.
There is some with congress,
but only some are with congress.
I think probably congress is beaten
up on too much, beaten
up on too much.
It's possibly beaten up on
more, maybe not more today
than it was I'm not sure about this.
But I think maybe there's too
much media beat up out there.
Let me give you some instances,
I've got four instances
of the way the media mislead us.
And I say this because this is a
congressional history conference
so at the least, we
should be thinking history.
And we should be thinking
about answering the phone
where a reporter calls up or
a student asks the question
and giving them something
that is reasonably true
about our congress
[inaudible] in history.
Four instances, four instances
of this of misleading.
One is this, we've
gone a hundred days
and they haven't passed any laws.
We've been hearing about this
in the last few months or so.
I looked back and here's
what I found,
I think this is roughly correct.
1933 was a genuine crisis and
they went on an immense binge
of lawmaking in March,
April, and May of 1933,
the depression and all that.
Since then, there's
only one instance
of a really important law passed
during the first hundred days
of a new president's term and that
was the stimulus bill in February 09
where there's another
crisis, another crisis
and since then it's a blank.
This is a fake yardstick and the
next time they call you up and ask
about it you should say
it's a fake yardstick.
Secondly, we've been hearing lately
or we've been hearing at least
under Obama that they
don't pass enough laws.
And the evidence for that lately
has become a list of laws that's put
out by -- I think it's by
the [inaudible] which as far
as I know is a very good list,
probably as accurate as you can get,
the government's very good.
But the use of this list
is terrible, it's taking it
as a measure of congressional
content or achievement innocent
of the fact that you're going to
be gathering together Obama care
with the declaration of national
petunia week and innocent
when you think over a period of
time with the strong likelihood
that in recent times more stuff has
been put into big omnibus bills.
Since more it is the
case that stuff is put
into big omnibus bills we
can have less fewer bills,
but we're not necessarily having
less content or less achievement.
The third point is this,
I think that the media
and this is true not
just in the media,
am I using this okay,
can you hear me, yeah?
The media overused
the term gridlock.
Gridlock in life in a traffic
jam is not a good thing.
You can look in the mirror and
comb your hair, you can do that
and so forth, but generally
speaking,
traffic jams are terrible
and we know that.
And in political science, there
is the use of the term gridlock
which is very fine, it's a positive,
analytic use as [inaudible] talked
about earlier and Keith
[inaudible] and some others.
But in the newspapers the
term gridlock had come to have
or does have as it applies to
congress a negative connotation.
They're not doing stuff,
they should be doing stuff
and they're not doing
stuff you see that.
Now we can all point to
instances where they're right,
there's some stuff they should
do and they haven't done it
like putting up the debt limit.
But for any society the more laws
passed would be an insane standard,
just an insane standard.
I mean you have to look back
and say is it a great idea
to be passing these laws.
I mean it's a wonderful thing
sometimes when congress deliberates
and fusses and frets
then does nothing.
It could be a great public
service when that is the result.
The fourth point is this
one, we here that the parties
that are running congress,
the majority parties,
they can't get their act
together, there it is.
It's a kind of platonic
form out there
of a point source party
that's supposed to be able
to operate perfectly with all
its members on the same page.
It's a fiction and generally
speaking in American history,
congressional majority
parties are not
like that, they'll vary somewhat.
But generally speaking, one of
the two parties is a slice --
a pretty large slice of American
life and there will be dissonance
between the parties, but there will
be dissonance within the parties.
Just look back in history you can
see this that is that Sam Rayburn
and Truman Kennedy had their
Dixiecrats, it was a big problem
within the party, within
the ruling party.
You ask President Taft and
Hoover and Coolidge and Harding
about the terrible problem
of dissident progressivists
within the republican party
on capitol hill those people
were impossible to deal
with decade after decade.
Ask Clinton about his blue dogs.
So, now we're getting with the
republicans we're getting the New
Jersey folks and the Arkansas
folks and it's like herding cats.
But this is pretty normal stuff.
Beyond that there's the question
of whether we should really like it
if they can get their
act together the parties.
It's not clear as an analytic or an
empirical it's a theoretical matter
that it's a great thing for the
parties to get their act together.
>> Mickey Edwards: That was great.
>> David Obey: Let
me start by saying
that my favorite political
scientist is Archie the Cockroach.
And Archie observed once
that the important thing
in politics is not the system the
important thing is what you do
with any system you
happen to have and I fall
into that school, I believe in that.
In my view, there is nothing
wrong whatsoever with the congress
that sending 30 more Mickey Edwards
to the congress wouldn't cure.
Again, I don't say that
just because he's here,
I say that because I believe it.
If you want a congress
that is more cooperative
and less dysfunctional then you
ought to stop sending people
to congress whose self-declared
intention is to blow things
up rather than build things that's
the main thing that's the problem
with congress these days.
When I came to congress, the
congress was controlled largely
by southern white,
sometimes racist men.
And we reformed the institution in
many ways over the next five years.
And then that congress faced
Watergate and it faced Vietnam.
That institution was
able to handle those,
you may not like the
way they handled it,
but that institution was able
to deal with those issues.
For I think one reason because
they came from a generation
that had experience -- well
they had two common experiences,
the first was the Great Depression
and the second was World War Two.
And I think those instances
taught them that if you wanted
to get along, if you wanted to
work things out for the welfare
of the country that excuse me,
that they were all in it together.
They had a more communitarian
approach certainly to problems
than the congress has today.
That generation believed
that you needed
to knock the rough edges
off capitalism in order
to give everybody a
buy in economically.
And it also recognized
that sometimes
in a legislative body
it is more important
to protect the institution's ability
to function than it is to press
for that last inch of political
advantage in dealing with any issue.
Example, when Mickey and I ran the
foreign operations subcommittee,
appropriations subcommittee
on the outside.
For part of the time the
senate chairman was Bob Kasten,
a republican from Wisconsin.
When we sat down with our staff
to try to work out what we needed
to put in my mark which I was
going to present to the house
and then later what our position
is going to be in conference
with the senate the very first
question I always asked my staff was
what does Bob Kasten need
that we can afford to give him
so that everybody walks
away from the deal feeling
like they got something and that
it was responsible given the
constituencies they
had the answer to.
And I tried to do the same
thing thinking about Mickey.
If you want to know or if
you want to have an example
of what the problem is in the
congress today I invite you to look
at one sheet of paper, this one.
This is the seating chart of
the United States Senate in 1960
and I invite you to
look at the chart.
You will find names on the
republican side like Case, Keating,
Pearson, Simpson, Javits, Cooper,
Aiken, Saltonstall, Dirksen.
Those people were reasonable
partisans and they were able to work
on the other side of the
aisle without being devoured
by the threat of the
primary opponent.
And so, the place might've been --
it civil, at least it was civil even
if you didn't like some of the
legislation that it produced.
Compare that to what
happened in the house.
I became chairman in 1994 the first
time halfway through the session,
we were behind in our work and I
desperately wanted to finish all
of the bills that we had before
the end of the fiscal year.
We did that, but it wasn't because
I was so blessed smart it was simply
because I was able to walk across
the aisle, talk to a guy by the name
of Joe McDade who was the ranking
republican on the committee
and I said to Joe, Joe I know we'll
never agree on the numbers in each
of the bills for each
of the programs,
but at least can't we agree,
can't we get a bipartisan mark
for the 302B numbers in
the budget resolution.
In other words, in plain
English, couldn't we agree
on how many dollars would go
into each subcommittee even
if we differed within
that subcommittee
on where the dollars would go.
He did that that's the only reason
that we were able to pass all
of those appropriations bills
before the end of the fiscal year.
Compare that to the atmosphere
that Obama faced when on the night
of the inauguration you had
people like Eric Cantor meeting
at a restaurant in
downtown Washington pledging
that they would deny Obama
any victory on anything.
What that meant is that
they would oppose him
on things even if they
agreed with him.
The problem you have today, my major
objection to the congress today is
that they're artificial flights
that are created day after day.
And so, you have a fight over
things that people really agree on,
but for political reasons
they decide they're going
to make life miserable for
the other side of the aisle.
That's in my view what
has to change.
The stimulus was mentioned, it
was my responsibility to put
through the house the appropriation
portion of the stimulus package.
And so, to do that I want to my
ranking republican on the committee
and I said Jerry, here's
roughly what we would like to do.
I walked him through the five
categories that we were looking at
and I said, you know,
we would like this to be
as bipartisan as possible.
Would you shop this stuff
on your side of the aisle,
tell me what you'd like in the
bill, tell me what you don't want
in the bill, we're not
going to agree totally,
but we'll try to accommodate
whatever we can.
He simply grinned and
looked at me and said Dave,
I'm sorry instructions from
headquarters I can't play.
So, the most serious
economic problem
since the Great Depression I was
told that no matter what I did
as chairman of the
committee they'd kick the hell
out of me and they did.
That wouldn't have happened
in the congress that I came
to because I think there was
a generational difference
and that older generation while
I often differed with them
on substance they had a respect for
the institution and they recognized
that institutional values
are sometimes more important
than issue values.
So that's the way I see the
situation and I would also point
out if we're going to be looking
forward instead of backwards.
We have an irony facing us at this
point with Mr. Trump Speaker Ryan.
The hope expressed in a lot of
newspaper stories in this town
for a couple of months had been that
while Trump is off the reservation,
he's got his own run amok agenda,
but as a practical matter we've got
to rely on people like Paul Ryan
to moderate what trump does.
In fact, in some ways I
think it's just the opposite.
If Trump had on healthcare if he had
stuck to the kind of healthcare bill
that he had told the American people
he would pass he'd already have it
through both houses
because what he said
on the campaign trail did
not overreach in terms
of savaging the base bill.
But instead because of internal
caucus pressures Ryan insisted
on going much further than Trump
and attacking the basic safety net
aspects of that healthcare bill.
And that's I think going to be a
very interesting process to watch
because it means that Trump
initially ran his campaign
against the establishment
of his own party.
But in the end, he will
be the instrument by which
that party establishment tries
to deliver what is on their minds
in economic terms and that is
going after Medicaid and Medicare.
They want that so badly
they salivate.
And so, Trump isn't
the person who pushed
that that agenda is being pushed by
the house republican leadership not
so much by the senate
republican leadership.
But I think we're going to have a
very different role to be played
by Ryan and Trump than people
expected when Trump was elected.
>> Eric Schickler: Yeah, thanks,
thanks so much it's great --
a pleasure to be here on this panel.
And I guess what I want to say
is thinking about the framing
of the question about harnessing
versus countering polarization.
I also agree with Mickey
Edwards' point
that it's actually partisanship
as much as polarization
that we should be talking about.
I actually think that when you
think historically it's seems to me
that neither of those options
is actually the right one
and here's what I mean.
I think first in thinking
historically about what's going on,
I think it's wrong to look to
history for analogies in this case.
I don't think there actually is
a really good historical analogy
to the problems we face today.
There have been periods where the
parties have voted quite apart
and distinctly, but it's not clear
the processes generating it were the
same as what we have now.
But I do think that we should
think about historically
in the following sense that
polarization or this intensification
of partisanship is itself a
self-reinforcing historical process.
In other words, that a whole
variety of actors, institutions,
players in our politics
have essentially adapted
to this present polarized
partisan environment
and now have a stake
themselves in reinforcing it.
When we think about the structure
of the media and media voices,
the way organized groups
operate in politics,
the way primaries operate today.
And so, what you have is a whole
set of actors where the stakes
of your side winning becomes
so high that you're willing
to put up with an awful lot.
And I think the Trump
case is actually in a lot
of ways a perfect kind
of exemplar of that.
If you were to think if you'd asked
political scientists what's the kind
of thing that could upset
intense polarization
or partisanship it would be the
arrival on the scene of a president
who doesn't come from
within the party structure,
offers some positions
that are quite unorthodox,
and is you know is
everything that Trump is.
And what's happened is Trump
has become absorbed exactly
into the exact same partisanship
and polarization that we saw before.
And so, I think that
suggests to me that the idea
that there's some strategy
out there for reformers
to counter this I don't
think is right.
At the same time, the idea of just
harnessing it for good in some way.
I just don't think is realistic,
I think that the idea if what
that would mean is just empowering
party leaders you still face the
basic tension that we have a
checks and balances separation
of power system that's not
premised on that kind of governance
and we have an immensely diverse
country that's not really --
doesn't give a clear majority to
one side to implement that program.
So, it's not clear that would
solve any problem either.
So, then the question
is well what do we do
or how do we think about this.
And I guess I'd want to
make two points about that.
One is I think that in some ways
the deepest problem is the one
that Mickey Edwards
alluded to at the start,
which is a commitment
to the institution.
That what we have now is
essentially the partisanship
and policy cleavages have become
so sharp that the number of members
who are institutionalists, who
have some sense for congress's role
in the system and commitment
to upholding
that has become much, much smaller.
And the willingness to make any
trade-offs toward, you know,
when it comes to sacrifice, you
know, Dave Obey referred to giving
up a little on policy in order to
get by and that willingness to do
that for the institution
is just way down.
And, you know, this is the one
place I disagree with my, you know,
my mentor David Mayhew
about dysfunction.
Like the place where I see it
as really problematic I agree
with him entirely, it's
not the number of laws
that gets passed that's so
important, but it's the idea
that there were periods where
you could count on members
of both parties if there was a case
of executive abuses for example
or a foreign policy disaster,
both parties to step up.
Whether it's, you know, thinking
about Fulbright during the Vietnam
War or you'd think about cases
of republicans, at least some
republicans in the Nixon era.
And that assumption I
think doesn't hold anymore
and I think that's a problem.
And so, thinking about are there
ways to reinforce some commitment
to the institution, I
that's really critical.
And then secondly, I think
that what we should think
about is are there reforms that
can somehow either hold constant
partisanship or put it to the side.
In other words, are there ways to
appeal to other kinds of interests
that members have whether it's
electoral of personal power
or ideally congressional
capacity and power
that essentially bracket
partisanship.
In other words, that don't
have an immediate impact
on their partisan goals yet
serve these broader interests.
But I think the idea that
you're going to get democrats
and republicans to
unify on something
that has clear partisan
stakes or partisan effects
in the short-term I just don't
think that's going to happen.
Thank you.
>> Sarah Binder: Great, well thank
you very much for including me.
I have to say I think the
first book I probably read
on congressional reform was Congress
Against Itself from Walter Oleszek,
presumably down the hall somewhere
so and Roger Davidson of course.
I guess I have one quick thing to
say on dysfunction and then another
to follow up on Eric's
comments about reform.
I think on the dysfunction
question I'm totally onboard
with why we don't want to count
up numerators and count up laws
and the difficulties and
whether that's a reliable
or a valid measure, particularly
in a historical sense.
I would question though whether we
are really not dysfunctional given
the levels of public approval,
which although they've rebounded
from the depths of
the depths of the 7%,
which is probably meaninglessness
distinguished from zero.
But it's still quite low, so I mean
one possibility is congress actually
is making tough choices and passing
on popular things and
so approval is low.
But that doesn't seem to
quite fit it seems more likely
that there are problems out there
granted there's disagreement
about whether all things are
problems the parties disagree
about whether things are problems.
But the fact that there are
many issues on the plate,
very little happening and public
approval is getting quite low
suggests that there is at least
a crisis of legitimacy even
if it's not necessarily
a legislative crisis.
Second, I think I would just
raise just two points about
and these are both sort of obvious,
but just the sheer difficulty
of reform unless it's a
sheer partisan reform sort
of where Eric was going at the end.
Even the appeal to institutionalists
I think sometimes there could be
less than meets the
eye there as well.
And what I have in mind here
is in the late 80's I worked
for Lee Hamilton on the hill
who is every bit a Dave
Obey as Mickey Edwards.
And I once asked him after I had
left the hill and was working
on my dissertation about procedural
rights for minority parties.
I said Lee, why do you ever
as a majority party member,
why you ever create rights to
help out, procedural rights,
[inaudible] rights to help
out the minority party.
And Lee six foot plus looked
down at me and scratched
that Hoosier haircut and
he said, we create rights
to help the minority well
that must be a mistake.
At first that just blew my,
you know, four years of working
for who I thought was like the
most principled institutionalist
that there was.
But I took his point to be that
even the most well-intentioned
of reforms, meaning that the
reforms are tied typically
to particular policy choices
or policy pursued policy goals,
even those well-intentioned reforms
it's very hard to find tuned reforms
to get the outcomes that you want.
Compounded by the difficulty is
that the rules and practices,
but rules here in this case,
last of course far longer
than the coalitions that
put them into place.
And the difficulty here I just
think of examples this year
as [inaudible] every day talk about
reconciliation right and its purpose
versus how it's being tried to be
used by the two parties whether it's
on taxes or on Affordable Care Act.
And efforts to kind of update
rules, in this case laws,
congressional budget act also
create their own difficulties
for the Byrd Act and the
difficulties of then trying to live
under the Byrd Act and the pressures
it creates on parliamentarians,
let alone minorities majorities.
So, I think the issue here on the
difficulty of reform is borrowing
from Eric's work on sort of
the layering of institutions is
that we don't really ever get the
chance to take out a clean sheet
of paper and write the
institution that we want,
it is almost always laid on top
of these existing laws and rules.
It just it gives me pause when we're
thinking about could there be ways
to alter the institution.
I've just become quite a skeptic
given the difficulties of doing so.
And just one other point on reform
and the difficulties of reform.
Maybe this is just
hypothesis, it certainly --
it could be the case
that centralized institutions I
guess perhaps ironically may be more
difficult to reform.
Just thinking here, the examples
from the 1970's from Julian's work,
from new work by Emily
Baer at Minnesota,
by Oleszek and Davidson of course.
Just the amount of time it
took, a decade plus in order
to build the type of coalitions even
just within the democratic party
to build the type of coalitions
that could eventually
make a major change right.
Even just watching the birth of
the democratic study group how long
that took and just this sort
of teaching as I understand it,
trying to help democratic
members sort
of develop procedural
preferences which we talk a lot
about policy preferences.
But I think there's something
to be said about thinking
about how lawmakers develop
their procedural preferences.
And that's what I take away from
the 70's is how long it took
to make these [inaudible]
mark changes to the rules,
some of which obviously the
Budget Act are still here today.
But I would just I think as
I've grown old and gray come
to appreciate the difficulties
a little bit more of kind
of institutional frictions
and the difficulty
of building these effective
institutional reforms.
>> Matt Glassman: Thanks Sarah.
Before we open up the questions I
have one more general question I'd
like to bring to bear
for our panelists
and that's more current
events right to this week.
I think there's two
developments this week
that certainly are
[inaudible] change,
but seem to be the
institution changing.
One is that we have talk all of
a sudden of preemptive omnibus
in the appropriations process.
And that doesn't signal
kind of the complete failure
of the traditional process
it signals something.
And the second thing that's happened
this week is the perceived level
of secrecy that is being brought
to the AHCA in the senate,
which again secrecy is
nothing new on the hill,
but this certainly
seems like a new level.
I think Sarah wrote something
about this on Twitter that many
of us read or at least I read.
And I'd like to get the panel's
thoughts on those two things
because these seem like plausibly
big changes that are coming.
The idea of a preemptive
omnibus and complete scrapping
of the appropriations process
ahead of time, not just after a CR.
And also, the use of kind of
completely private means to deal
with large bills instead of going
through even kind of the paces
of something that looks like the
traditional committee process,
development process of legislation.
>> David Obey: Well I
wouldn't mind taking a --
well let me do something
a little bit different.
I'll comment on those, but first
I want to mention something
that I forgot in the first instance.
I don't want to leave the
impression that I don't think
that there are any reforms that
might improve the situation,
but I don't think they are
necessarily congressional reforms.
The two that I have in mind
are first of all redistricting
and my state is a good example and
I would urge you to watch that suit
that is now working its way
up the Supreme Court
it's really interesting.
It's a suit from Wisconsin's
legislative redistricting.
But in Wisconsin two elections
ago the republicans got 48 1/2%
of the vote and yet they elected
almost two thirds of the members
of the state assembly because
of the way they drew the line.
Lest you think I'm being
partisan, democrats did same thing
to the republicans in Illinois.
And the problem with that isn't just
that the losing party is hurt the
problem is that when that happens,
when you create so
many districts that are
so one-sided either democratic or
republican, you destroy incentives
for compromise because
then all members have to do
to get reelected is
to satisfy their base.
If I hear the word base once more
from either party I will
gag to death so help me God.
The second thing is
campaign-finance.
When I first got into politics
I spent $1,160 to get elected
to the [inaudible] County
Second Assembly District.
In this last election, Betsy
DeVos' pack poured $400,000
into that state, that
same state assembly race.
When you do -- now we're
in the business of trying
to recruit another
candidate for that district.
Nobody will want to run because
they will say how in hell do I raise
that kind of money, so not
only do you deprive people
of any meaningful vote in a
lot of these safe districts,
but you also make it unlikely
that you're going to get a lot
of quality candidates in the future.
The third is internal
with the house.
I think the main problem with
the Budget Act is simply this,
the budget committee brings out its
ideas, it's flying at 30,000 feet.
What they do is they lay out the
macro numbers, but they don't get
around to applying those numbers
to each individual program.
So, then the house passes
the budget resolution.
Then after the budget
resolution gets passed
because it's a generalized press
release rather than a budget.
Then poor Hal Rogers got stuck
with the job of having to translate
that general package of ideas
into specific program
by program legislation.
That's when members of the house who
voted for the budget resolution say
to Hal Rogers, you expect me to vote
to cut what, are you crazy as hell,
I'm not going to do that.
And so, the appropriations
committee gets the heat
because the budget committee
overreached in its estimate
of how much you could cut from a lot
of programs and safety net and so
that winds up slowing down
the whole institution.
So, I think it is the
overreaching of the budget committee
to use the budget resolution
to go just 1 inch from the wall
in order to get a product out.
I think that's the main
problem with the Budget Act.
And so, if I had my way I
would abolish the Budget Act
or not the Budget Act,
but the budget committee.
Short of that what I would do is
make the chairman of ways and means
and appropriations cochairman
or at least make them rotating
so that the guy who presents the
brilliant ideas for budget cuts
in the budget resolution has to then
carry them out on real legislation.
>> Mickey Edwards: Yeah,
well let me to add here.
First of all, yeah I totally
agree, I mean [inaudible].
I was on a panel one time years ago
with a number of the leadership,
I was in the leadership then on
our side and a number of republican
and democratic leaders speaking
at a big conference like this.
And the only thing
that we agreed on was
that creating the budget committee
was a mistake so, you know,
I just lay that out there.
So, I just want to make a couple
of points before we
get to the questions.
First is Professor
Mayhew's comments,
he's right there are problems here,
we're focused on the
congress in particular.
But the problems that we face are
more than that, they're social,
they're cultural, they're
universities
that don't really teach the
humanities in critical thinking
and civics and that have become
essentially voc-tech schools
teaching people how to make a living
as opposed to how to be citizens.
It's corporate short-term
greed, it is the same thing
with the media as corporations.
You know there are so many
kinds of things out there
that we're not really going to fix
it if we only focus on, you know,
the specifics about the operation
of congress there are bigger reasons
for the problems that we are facing.
And I just want to say a
word to you all, I've had --
I've been lucky enough to
do some teaching my own,
I wasn't very good not like
you, but I taught for 11 years
at the Kennedy School then I
taught at the Wilson School.
And one of the things that I
observed and I have great admiration
of your professions, but I
think there's also an obligation
to be careful about where there
are so many things that are hard
to put hard numbers on that
you have to make assumptions,
you have make leaps of things
that you can't quantify.
And I think you need
to be a little careful
about instilling cynicism
about the system.
Instilling cynicism in your
students about why members
of congress do what they do.
Even though I was in the
minority every single day I was
in congress members on both
sides of the aisle that I knew,
including the majority were people
who didn't have this
clever calculating strategy
about whether they're going to offer
an amendment or where they're going
to -- they believed
things, they have views,
they have sincere beliefs.
And they go there to try to carry
out the beliefs that they have
and that their constituents have
and you have to be really careful
about inadvertently, you know,
having your students walk
out of there with the idea that this
is a bunch of crooks out, you know,
just to, you know,
feather their own nest
or pursue their own private agendas.
And so, I think we need to rebuild
institutional pride in congress
and I think that you all
have a role to play in that.
>> Matt Glassman: Well we
have about half an hour,
which is about two thirds of the
time that we're supposed to reserve
for audience questions,
so do we have the mics?
>> David Mayhew: [Inaudible]
down here.
>> Matt Glassman: Yes.
>> I didn't see who you're
pointing to, I'm sorry.
>> Matt Glassman: Yup,
down here to Richard.
>> So, I enjoyed all those comments.
I particularly enjoyed the ideas
that reform of congress is something
that can't be internal to congress.
That a lot of the problems
that we see
with congress are in fact external.
I also think they can't
be controlled.
But let me talk just
a little bit about it.
David wrote a book some
time ago, America's Congress
and America's Congress had imagined
a public sphere in which members
of congress took positions
and they took positions
that were daring and
they were risky.
And to creating the congress
was to create an institution
in which those opportunities to
take positions in the public sphere
that were daring, these were the
good ones, there were some bad ones.
But the good ones was to grab the
attention of the American people
and say, this is wrong or this
is right or whatever it would be.
But there was a public sphere
and this public sphere in the way
that David modeled it in
the book was fairly unified
in how it paid attention,
it knew what was daring,
it knew what was a moral
stand, it knew the logics
within which people were taking
these positions and so forth.
The thing that has happened not just
since that book, but David like many
of the books we write are right
on the cusp of major change is
that public sphere has
largely disintegrated.
And it's disintegrated because
now we have multiple spheres,
the big three television stations,
the big organs and newsmagazines
and so forth that created
a common platform in which
that daring move would be
reported to everybody in sort
of the same way that's gone.
So, you know, it's hard for
me even to imagine a member
of congress making a daring
position anymore that would be yes,
they're taking a moral stand and
it's not characterized that way.
I mean it's Fox News will do it one
way, CNBC will do it another way,
you'll see it in CNN another way.
There is not a single -- this gets
back to the institutional thing,
but one of the things that's
happened with the institution
and institutional affiliation
is we've lost a common logic
about how we think
about causal connections
between things that happen.
So, climate change the causal
connections that are imagined in one
of these public spheres is
that scientists are just
feathering their own nests
and in the other spheres this is
science and asserts it as truth.
But there's not a single attention
to the causal mechanisms themselves
as being claims on policy.
That's all extraneous to congress,
that seems to me beyond the ability
of congress to control, they
shouldn't try to control it.
But boy it looks like
a major factor.
>> David Mayhew: I think
that's finely said.
I would say that in the past when we
did have senators and house members
who made a big fuss
with some consequence
in the public sphere often
they were quite sectarian.
I mean you take Charles
Sumner and slavery
or you take Robert La Follette
with this, that or another.
It's not as if they were speaking
for a consensus they were out there.
And there's a certain similarity
to folks like Bernie Sanders
who spends a day on the senate
floor or Ted Cruz who spends a day
on the senate floor
making some kind of case.
The senate is still there
to engage in that kind
of what public mobilization
it's there.
>> Eric Schickler: Yeah,
I think it's there,
but I think the problem is
you always had members who did
that that could be lumped in or
seen as partisans, but you also had
and so that the statement
would be reported as such,
you had a greater share
of I think counter.
You know I mean think
about La Follette,
it's La Follette is the
progressive republican taking
on his own party right.
And we don't have the equivalent of
that in the same way I think now.
And I do think that there -- I think
the media point though is important
in terms of the reinforcement
of incentives.
You know the problem is
that if you think of --
I think it's certainly it's not
about the goodwill or the principles
of the individual members,
it's a matter of you know can
I do this and will it work.
And as long as you have a media
universe that's bifurcated
in this way or fragmented in
this way makes it much harder
for a member to see the reward
and effectiveness in taking a kind
of counter stereotypical bold stand
as opposed to taking the bold stand
that just reinforces the line.
>> I want to just make a
couple of points about various
because I take the point
that Professor Mayhew makes
about not over-refocusing
on congress
and looking at external features.
And also, the fact that congress
is facing these problems over time.
But I think it's worth
making the point
that there are some unique aspects
to the contemporary congress
and that is its persistent failure
to address high priority issues.
The fact that we've gone year after
year with virtually no action taken
on issues that I think
most people recognize
as being not only significant, but
where there are significant levels
of public support whether
that's around immigration policy
or unemployment policy
or around gun policy and
yet no action taken whatsoever
I think does differentiate.
And the way I would remind people
broadly about that is it's not
that long ago that you did have
a congress that was able even
in a situation of divided government
to address highly controversial
issues.
If you look back to 2008, we were
able with a republican president
and democratic congress
to pass a stimulus bill
to address the financial crisis and
to pass car bailout legislation,
notwithstanding the fact that there
were high levels of partisanship,
not within the fact that there
was the continuing struggle
for congressional control.
I do think and I forget
exactly who made this point,
I think a lot of this does go
back to not necessarily the nature
of the institution alone, but
to the individuals who are
in the institution, what their
objectives are which is one
of the reasons why I think if you
only deal with congressional reform
at the point at which people arrive
in congress you're bound to fail
because they've gotten there
by virtue of processes.
Whether that's nominations or
financial rewards or media attention
that reward them for taking
the most extreme positions
and unlikely having gotten
there under those circumstances
to take daring positions.
I think you've really got to
look at the primary system,
I think however fanciful
it sounds you have to look
at the campaign finance and perhaps
you can build some broader public
support around those types
of crosscutting structural
change issues that will build
and provide some bipartisan support
for addressing those
kinds of issues.
But simply railing at people who
are rewarded on a daily basis
for taking extreme positions,
to take moderate positions
or to take collaborative
positions seems to me something
of a fool's errand
it's simply not going
to work that's not
how they got there
and that's not how they secure
their rewards which is reelection.
>> David Mayhew: A
couple of brief reports.
One is that you mention 2008
stimulus I think that's a very
good instance.
But another recent instance would
be under Obama, I mean Pelosi
and Boehner and Obama
dealing year after year
with the country's
fiscal difficulties
and bad optics no question, but
they really did bleach the deficit
and the debt over there
about four years
or so that's really quite
consequential legislating them.
Another brief one immigration,
I think you take all the
American history back
to the 1870's the lawmaking
and immigration
on the record today
is quite difficult.
I mean it's always been difficult
to do immigration policy.
The country has gone decades and
decades and decades of pressure
to do immigration policy and they
never did anything until just
after World War One
as a circumstance
of refugees coming in
after World War One.
And then in the 1960's when
all the Anglophone countries
for whatever reason were passing
immigration loosening bills.
Otherwise, it's largely
a desert the history
of immigration policymaking,
but is quite difficult.
>> I'd like to follow
up on that one,
but I think that's exactly a
good point because in 2013,
the senate did pass a
bipartisan immigration bill
and what happened was it
came over to the house
and they wouldn't even allow it
to come up in the subcommittee
for a hearing or they wouldn't
even allow the senate bill to come
to the floor for a vote and.
>> David Mayhew: Quite
right, but over 160 years
or so failure is the norm
on immigration policy,
it's not a new thing.
It's a very difficult thing to
put together winning coalitions
across the whole government
on immigration policy,
it always has been.
>> But in point of fact, had
they put that senate proposal
on the floor it would have passed.
And so, it goes to the
question of the people
who were there and the vote.
>> David Mayhew: I think
you're right about that,
put it on the floor it
probably would've passed in more
than one congress, maybe two.
But there we are that's another
that's an intensity was feeding
into congress and that could happen
also that on the republican side.
>> Mickey Edwards: Well I want
to pick up on the first part John
of what you said which
was about what's fixable.
So, one of the things I know I
harp on, but 2% of the population
of Texas, 2% voting in a runoff
primary made Ted Cruz the only
republican allowed to be
on the general election
ballot in a republican state.
In Utah 1/10th of 1%
of the population
in a convention kept Robert
Bennett from running for the senate
for reelection which he would've
won and that's why we ended
up with Mike Lee and Ted Cruz
in the senate when the majority
of the people in their state
would not have elected them.
And so, unless we begin
to really say
where in the system are there
problems that can be fixed
and that will produce a different
kind of senator or house member
at the end of the process
we're going to be stuck
with this for a long time.
>> David Obey: Let me also
buttressing what you said John.
One of my great frustrations when
I was chairman of the committee was
that we had no such thing as
a filibuster in the house,
but nonetheless we had a
filibuster in the house every day.
And that was accomplished by
introducing 150 amendments
to each appropriation bill
as they were brought
before the rules committee.
And the strategy on the part of
the minority at that time was
to simply slow walk us so we could
not in any way finish our business
and then they would attack us
for not finishing our business.
Steny Hoyer and I in public on
the house floor had a dialogue
with John Boehner on this
and we tried to find some way
to give the Republicans a
reasonable number of amendments,
but still enable us
to finish our work.
And Boehner was willing to do that,
we met in private and we worked
out an agreement, came
back to the floor.
And when we tried to pass it Boehner
had a revolution in his own caucus,
he was in good faith negotiating
and he got his legs cut
off by the tea party types.
And that isn't the only time that
you've had that inconsistency.
This is not just something
that happened along the way
in the history of the house it
was purposeful and determined.
And if you -- I would
invite one other comparison.
Look at what happened
when George Bush Junior W.
when he presented the tarp
package to the congress,
it went down the first time,
but it passed the second
time with bipartisan support.
That was a hard vote to cast, I
think it's the best vote I ever cast
in the house, but it
was very unpopular.
But you had bipartisan
support for that.
That was the first half
of the economic crisis
legislation that was dealt with.
The second half was the stimulus
package, but when that package came
up we got no help whatsoever.
That's not a historical incident
that is a determined policy
of simply bringing
the institution down,
as well as the party that runs it.
>> Matt Glassman: Josh.
>> Hi, I'd like to talk a
little bit more about some
of the internal changes
that are being discussed,
particularly in the house.
And one of things that struck me in
the opening remarks how it's hard
to draw historical comparisons
between this era and previous ones.
But when I look at congress today
I see all sorts of similarities
to the 1910's, the 1920's
and the 19 [inaudible]
and things of that nature.
Matt pointed out that there's
a very secretive bill going
through the house and the senate
that's being negotiated behind
closed doors.
And then the committees were
simply rubberstamping it
and then sending it to the floor.
That doesn't sound too different
than the democratic team caucus
as we talked about
in the early 1910's.
Or for example, the arguments
that are being made by the house
of freedom caucus members, the
similarities between Justin Amash,
republican member from
Michigan and Congressman Hepburn
who is a republican
member from Iowa back
in the 1900's are almost
strikingly similarity
in how much pushback they have
against centralized
power and the leadership.
In other words, what I'm asking
is do you think that the types
of arguments that are being made
by this group that's blowing
up government essentially
amongst their own leaders,
does it have teeth or
is it just bluster?
>> David Obey: Well
it's got teeth enough
to destroy Boehner's speakership,
it had teeth enough to insist
that the caucus abide
by the Hastert Rule.
So, I would not underestimate
their ability
to blow things up whenever
they want.
>> Sarah Binder: One thing
to add is just to think
of the broader partisan
context in which you have
that type of factionalism right.
If you have 1910 you have two
parties where the factions are
in the middle right, so there's some
cross-party coalitions you're able
to get the place to work right,
even if it costs right the
speaker eventually his job.
But if you have the factions coming
from in this case the far right
and the [inaudible] of polarization,
obviously there's no cross-party
coalition right that's going
to help them out right.
Like Charlie Dent bless his
soul isn't going to line
up with Nancy Pelosi
any day even though
that could create a new
winning cross-party coalition.
So, I think it matters not
just where the factions are,
but where the broader array
of the parties are in terms
of whether it's going to make
the system still be [inaudible].
>> Eric Schickler: Just to build
real quickly off of Sarah's point,
I mean I think that's exactly right.
I mean it's not that there are
no similarities or parallels,
but the structural situation that
was distinctive throughout most
of American history was
that you would have factions
within the majority party that
one could see plausibly working
with the minority party and that had
a substantial impact on incentives.
Now there are a whole range of
factors that cut against that
and so I think make
that less likely.
I think this goes back to the Mainer
case is actually a really good one
for thinking about why it's
tempting to say what we need is
to centralize more power in
leaders and yet why I think
that ultimately is
not going to work.
Because the problem is
no matter how much power,
formal power one grants the speaker
of the house if there is a faction
of members in that party
that's potentially pivotal
that want something else and
is willing to take, you know,
and has a strong electoral
interest and personal, you know,
ideological interest in pursuing
that no amount of carrots and sticks
that you grant Boehner is
going to take a cohesive group
like the freedom caucus potentially
and disempower them ultimately.
You can try but ultimately,
it's just not going to work.
So, the idea that just giving
more power to the speaker is going
to discipline the factions
and allow them
to govern effectively I
think is just a pipe dream.
>> David Obey: There is no
requirement to the democracy
that there be a happy ending.
>> Could I ask, for me always one
of the striking parts of the 60's
and 70's beyond Richard Bowlings
[phonetic] that Sarah was referring
to is just the way in which social
movements, the major movements,
civil rights, the antiwar movement
took the congressional process
as something to focus on and
were part of all these efforts
to build attention to reform and
to round up votes from reform.
Even the union movement
and Andrew B. Miller
and others were there
kind of working on this.
A, is that still the case today with
all these groups, climate change,
immigration reform, Black
Lives Matters on the right,
the tea party that are invested
in a better system are they kind
of paying attention to trying
to fix the legislative process
and if they are, why
are they less effective
than what we saw in
the 60's and 70's?
>> Sarah Binder: Well there was
a great group called Action Not
Gridlock in 93 and 94, it's
paid for by the Labor AFL,
hey it's been a long day AFLCIO
which was trying to build support
for generating a filibuster
reform in the senate.
And I went, Steve Smith and I were
working on a filibuster book we went
to go and find them in 1995
and the doors were closed.
Funding was yanked,
it had disappeared.
So, in part, I guess one question is
whether the groups are more closely
aligned with parties in their
partisan agenda that would lead them
to turn on a dime once they realize
the consequences of particular types
of reform that's one possibility.
>> Mickey Edwards: Two
things [inaudible].
One is that both parties
now and most
of the outside groups there
is far more focus just
on the executive branch.
You know talk to the agencies,
talk to the departments
as though they have forgotten you
know the role that congress plays
and that it could be
the final say in that,
I think that's a significant
part of it.
The other is that there is -- as
they bring these ideas forward
about what their causes are
on both sides of the aisle,
on both left issues
and right issues,
too few people now care
at all about process.
They want the outcome they want
no matter what process it takes
to get there.
And the result of that is to
undermine the legislative process
as we go along, you know,
and so then the members
of congress start doing
the same thing.
I've seen the democrats
did it under Pelosi,
the republicans have done it.
And that is, this is the
outcome we want and we'll skip --
we'll go around the process
if that's what it takes
to get the victory and that's
really doing great damage.
You know there has to be a respect
for what the process is
whether it's a justice issue,
whether it is an economic issue
and I don't see that anymore.
I mean I gave a talk one time called
does the constitution still matter
to you and I find not a whole
lot of people who think it does.
You know the constitution
and the ways
that the legislative process
is supposed to work just seem
to be almost irrelevant to a lot of
people who want the bill they want.
>> David Obey: Let me
give you an example
of how important processes can be.
It would be nice if congressional
leadership understood process
and I've seen time after
time when they didn't.
One story, Bill Young
was ranking republican
on the Appropriations Committee
and then he was chairman
of the Appropriations Committee,
he and I were very good friends.
And during an especially nasty
period when the budget wasn't moving
and appropriations weren't
moving Bill said to me,
I just have to tell you
something, I said what's up.
He said, yesterday I was called
into the speaker's office,
this was Hastert's office.
And he said, the speaker
said you've got to get
down here right away we've got a
revolution on our hands and you have
to answer some questions.
So, Bill said I went down and I
walk into the speaker's office
and the speaker said to me
with a bunch of tea party types
in the room, Bill we've got people
who are very restless about inaction
on the appropriation bill, when can
you start bringing appropriation
bills to the floor.
And Hastert said or I
mean Bill said to Hastert,
well first I have to
have an allocation.
By that he meant that
the budget committee had
to give the Appropriations
Committee the dollar number
that the Appropriations
Committee could then divide
up into 13 subcommittees
and move the bills.
And Bill said, well I have
to have an allocation.
Hastert's response was
what's an allocation.
Now when people that close to power
in that institution don't know
what the hell they're doing
on a procedural basis
is it any wonder
that the institution
gets screwed up.
>> David Mayhew: On process,
a couple of process points,
there are a couple of things that
for us history of congress folks,
there are possibly a couple
of us to keep in mind.
One is this the Hastert Rule wherein
the majority party in the house
so going by the likes of its
median member simply dominates.
It snuck up on us, it's norm not a
role, it's a party role, it's a norm
and it's a practice, it's a behavior
to somewhat degree followed
I suppose as behavior
on the democratic side,
it kind of snuck up on us.
I mean the Hastert Rule has got like
what 25 years, something like that,
I don't know where it
came it's like an implant.
I think it's an implant that
doesn't really work very well.
I don't think it's a great
way to run the house.
The other point is this
on the other filibuster,
the flagging filibuster
in the senate right now.
I think it's good for us to
keep in mind as now we're going
to be considering this
and watching this again
over the next few years I think
the filibuster stuff in the senate
that the country and this has
been written about by Shukla Moron
and by Greg Koger very nicely.
It's that the country went for about
200 years without having a hard
and fast filibuster blockade
practice in the senate, you know,
a hard veto point, I mean the hard
veto point where you could just say,
you don't have 60 votes you're
toast over a whole list of issues.
I mean that's the development of
the 1980's, it just wasn't there
across American history and we
should know that, we should know
that and we should keep saying it.
It's not in not the constitution,
it's not in the Magna Carta,
I mean the toughness
of the appellate practice
comes [inaudible] the 1980's.
>> Matt Glassman: We've got time
for one more quick question, anyone?
Okay well thank you to
our panelists and we are.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.